I'm going to be revisiting some
unsupervised pre-trading stuff today
this is reconstruction based methods as
opposed to the contrastive methods that
we looked at on Monday
all right so the plan for today we're
going to do a little recap on what
Chelsea talked about on Monday so we're
going to talk about the unsupervised
learning problems set up and just just
go over contrastive learning briefly and
then the the meat of the lecture is
going to be about reconstruction based
unsupervised pre-training so the main
difference here is that we're not
learning by comparing multiple examples
we're sort of learning one example at a
time by just trying to compute a
representation and then reconstruct the
example and we're going to talk about a
couple different instantiations of this
idea some of them you've probably heard
of before some of these big fancy
hopefully not scary models and a lot of
this content is going to be stuff that's
homework three is is on so it behooves
you to to pay attention
and you're the people who came so you're
already ahead of the curve and if you
pay attention you'll be even farther
ahead of the curve so hopefully by the
end of the lecture you'll have some
familiarity with with some of these now
pretty widely used methods for for
unsupervised pre-training and and some
of the ways that we can then fine-tune
these models once we've pre-trained them
and ideally be ready to
um Breeze through homework three
all right so just to start this recap so
as Chelsea said on Monday a new
unsupervised learning we have some large
unlabeled data set ideally a diverse
unlabeled data set we do this first gray
Arrow which is unsupervised pre-training
and this gives us our pre-trained model
and then once we have our pre-trained
model we usually use some often small
data set for a fine tuning to specialize
this model to a particular task and the
goal is to get sort of a good predictive
model for this particular task
and uh you know after that we talked
quite a bit about contrastive learning
on Monday so the the basic idea here is
that examples that are similar in some
sense should have similar
representations
and so this could be examples that have
the same class label this could be
examples that just come from nearby
regions of an image if we don't have
class labels it could be augmented
versions of the same example by flipping
or cropping or adding noise or if we
have sort of temporally structured data
like videos we can take video frames
that come near each other in time to get
sort of positive pairs
another thing that we talked about is
it's not good enough to just take things
that are similar and push the
representations together because then we
end up with this degeneracy where
everything gets the same representation
so we actually need to contrast things
too and that's how we get this wonderful
name contrastive learning and sort of
the most straightforward implementation
of this is this triplet loss so here we
have a triplet because we have kind of
our anchor example and then we have a
positive example which we say is sort of
the similar one and then the negative
example which is different we push
together the similar ones and we we pull
apart the uh the negative ones
and then you can generalize this to have
more than one negative so this is this
sort of End Way classification loss
which is used in the The Sim clear paper
that you might remember which is which
is also known as the NT accent or
normalized temperature scaled
cross-entropy loss which is really
um an awesome name
um one one minor correction from from
Monday is there were some questions
about whether or not the the similarity
score for the positive pair shows up in
the numerator and the denominator and
and it does so in the Sim clear loss we
have a similarity score uh for the for
the positive pair in both the numerator
and the denominator and the reason
that's useful is
um since we have this positive score in
the denominator and the the
um the numerator we know that this
fraction is going to be between zero and
one and so we can sort of interpret this
as a classification probability and so
really we can kind of just think about
this contrastive objective as like
training a classifier with our
representation so it makes it a little
easier to think about the loss and what
it's doing
like how do we feel
yeah that's that's I love I love the
enthusiasm keep bringing the energy
folks
um okay so now let's talk about some
reconstructive uh reconstruction based
uh unsupervised objectives so again
um the main difference
between these methods and the contrasted
methods are we're not comparing and
contrasting multiple examples we're sort
of doing this one example at a time
which makes things a little easier
and the simple intuition for these
methods is that a good representation of
our data is one that lets us reconstruct
it so if we have some image love this
lovely little dog we might pass it
through our encoder to get a
representation and ideally if we have a
good representation
we should be able to decode this
representation back into our original
input and and ideally with a decoder
that's not absolutely massive it should
be sort of a reasonably a reasonable
size decoder
and sort of the bonus of this type of
setup is that we don't have to worry
about things like sampling negatives or
using large batch sizes because again
this objective is purely defined on just
a single training example and so we
don't have this sort of more complicated
relationship between multiple examples
in a batch to worry about
okay so that gives you a little bit of a
flavor what we're talking about we can
make it a little more concrete
so we have this this intuition that a
good representation is what lets us
reconstruct the input so how do we
actually train the thing well we really
just Define some loss function that
tells us how close our reconstruction is
to the original input so for images we
might use just L2 or squared L2 distance
and then we train this whole thing end
to end so we train the the encoder and
the decoder end to end and hopefully by
the end our encoder gives us
representations that are useful so
that's that's kind of a neat story but
I'm curious if people have any um
creeping suspicions on what can go wrong
in this situation
if you've ever trained a VA you might
know the answer
everything it is included under
everything yes
you saw my slides didn't you
very impressive so yes I mean one way to
think about this is according to this
last function we've written down with
the identity function be a good encoder
or decoder
that's not actually totally rhetorical
I'm curious if it would be
so the answer is yes it would be um
because if we have the identity function
as an encoder R is just X and if the
decode is the identity function X hat is
X or loss is zero
um and that's like a great loss function
or a great encoder and decoder for this
loss but it's not really useful so the
question is how do we fix this
um and there are a lot of different ways
to fix this but we're going to focus on
one common one that people use so if R
is basically unconstrained if it's just
as high dimensional as our input
then there's no reason the encoder can't
just copy the input into the
representation and then the decoder just
copies that representation to be its
prediction and this is not really useful
we're not learning anything meaningful
and so the key idea that people use to
kind of get around this issue is adding
some sort of a bottleneck on our
representation so the most common maybe
most intuitive type is just make it
lower dimensional so we might have an
image that's like you know 100 by 100
pixel pixels
um and our representation might only be
64 Dimensions so you know intuitively
it's much harder to just copy the whole
image into this low dimensional space
and so the hope is that these latent
dimensions in our representation will
actually be forced to represent some
high level Concepts that are more kind
of efficient in storing information than
just memorizing one pixel at a time
okay so let's say we train this model
now because we have this encoder that
compresses our input into some more
compact in some sense representation
how do we actually do the few shot
learning part well we'll throw away our
decoder and we can just initialize a
prediction head on top of this
representation so really what we've just
learned is a feature extractor of our
data and now we'll just treat this as a
normal machine learning problem we can
fit some sort of prediction head to
these representations instead of the raw
images this could be an MLP or it could
just be like an svm or whatever
um and uh we'll we'll train it to to
make classification scores so here if
we're doing like five-way classification
we just have a classifier now
and you know the simplest recipe here is
we'll freeze the encoder and just fine
tune uh this prediction head or just fit
the prediction head
okay so so this is the basic Auto
encoder or bottlenecked autoencoder
setup which is kind of the you can maybe
think of like the simplest thing that
kind of works
um and the pros here are that it is very
simple it's very general you can kind of
do this for pretty much any sort of data
because all you need to do is pick this
lost this distance function which which
you can you can usually come up with
some sort of distance function from most
data modalities
you also have this Advantage compared to
contrastive learning that we don't need
to select these positive and negative
Pairs and this is often the sort of most
difficult part of the contrastive
learning setup and so it's really nice
to get rid of that
um but the the major downsides here
um in particular is that we have to
design this bottlenecking mechanism
um and and turns out this is really hard
to do well so you can use this sort of
low dimensional bottleneck in practice
this doesn't really give you that good
of representations even if you make it
relatively low dimensional
um and and you might wonder well why is
that
um and and you you uh a lot of this is
known mostly just empirically by by
training them but um what you end up
with is still sort of representations
that mostly memorize the images and
don't actually encode uh sort of any
sort of high level or interpretable
concepts that are likely to generalize
well beyond just reconstructing this
exact image
um and you really do kind of end up with
representations that just encode the
specific details needed to minimize the
Reconstruction loss but not really
anything that is is easily adaptable to
new tasks and so so what ends up
happening a lot of the time is R is more
like a hash of your input than than a
sort of conceptual summary
um and if you think about you know for
example using like the gzip
representation of an image as its
representation for fine tuning like
that's not going to be a very
informative representation even though
it's going to be smaller than the
original image and so just compressing
is not uh at least in this sense of
dimensionality is not good enough to to
actually Force our encoder to squeeze
out sort of useful reusable features
so how do we encourage the encoder to
extract these high-level reusable
features and one strategy that people
use is just other types of bottlenecks
so we can we can
bottleneck our representation in many
ways we can use information bottlenecks
that essentially add noise to the
representation we can use sparsity
bottlenecks that constrain the number of
Dimensions that can be non-zero we can
also use capacity bottlenecks to force
the decoder to be relatively weak so
that the the representation needs to be
sort of easy to decode
um but the the strategy that actually is
is most common in practice is
um to worry less about designing a
bottleneck and just make the task a
little bit more difficult to force the
encoder to learn something a little less
trivial
and that's going to take us to our our
next section on masked autoencoders
which is sort of a class of models that
encompasses a lot of the the large
pre-trained models that we have these
days that we use in practice
how are we doing so far
any questions
is everyone having fun though
yes
strapping information about examples
yeah so in a sense you can so it depends
on the exact model and and the the
capacity and the training data but
um you know in the same way that you can
hash functions are generally difficult
to invert but but if they're imperfect
you can invert them a lot of the times
yeah you can not only just decode a
particular representation back into its
image but you can kind of fiddle with
these models in a way that lets you
extract multiple examples from the
training distribution which can pose
sort of a privacy risk
does that great
expectations
um since the model is kind of just
memorizing details from the original
initially if you just selected computing
yeah so I mean if you have
um I guess the question is uh if the
representations aren't that great like
can we sort of get around that by just
making our predictor higher capacity and
we definitely can if we have a lot of
data that we're able to fine tune on but
the idea is uh in in the best case
setting we're going to learn
representations that let us perform well
on our Downstream tasks with really
simple predictors right because the
simple predictors are the ones that we
can fit with only a little bit of data
that are very difficult to sort of
overfit with
um and so if we if we need to do this
sort of thing that sort of means like
our objective is not working very well
because ultimately it just means we're
not going to be able to do few shot
learning as well because we'll need a
lot of data to find team with
[Music]
yeah so I mean you you could imagine
um sort of like a cross encoder where
like instead of reconstructing X you
reconstruct like xpaws
yeah so
um I don't there's not a specific paper
I'm thinking of that's like extensively
evaluated this sort of thing but
um sort of colloquially yeah you can do
that I'm not sure how it directly uh
compares to stuff like like Bert or
um
yeah any of these models here but in a
way
that sort of is what Mast Auto encoders
do they they in a sense they do come up
with these positive Pairs and then
just hang on all right
um but if you're still wondering that at
the end come grab me
all right so we want to go beyond this
bottlenecked approach to the
autoencoders because uh designing a good
bottleneck that actually
um forces our encoder to give us good
features is is uh really quite tricky
and so the the common solution people
use now is called mass autoencoders and
the issue that this sort of gets around
is like our regular Auto encoders are
really trying to predict X from like X
and you know this is sort of a
degenerate task
and so we add this bottleneck to try to
avoid our degenerate Solutions but maybe
the task is just too easy and the the
easiest way to solve the issue is not to
design a really fancy or really perfect
bottleneck but just make the task a
little bit harder and so that's sort of
the approach that we're taking with mass
auto encoders where we no longer predict
X from X
um instead we we just mask out a little
bit of the input and we try to
reconstruct the other part of the input
and so in this sense uh going back to
your question earlier we sort of are
doing this in that now X and Y are not
the same they're sort of like this
positive pair that's generated by
literally just like partitioning the
input into pieces
um and this does work really well so
you're just like five years too late
but otherwise that would have been like
a brilliant research idea
um so that's sort of the gist of mass
auto encoders and this is even though
this is a relatively small departure
from the outer encoders we already saw
it's a really really powerful framework
for representation learning that is is
uh pretty widely applicable
okay so let's let's go over kind of the
general recipe
um for for how mass auto encoders get
trained in practice so again just like
when we're training a regular
autoencoder we need to pick some sort of
distance function that tells us how good
our reconstructions are uh given the the
original input so this part is the same
and then for a training batch of
examples for each example what we're
going to do first is we're going to
sample what we're going to Define which
is a masking function so we're going to
take that example and we're going to
generate X tilde which is sort of the
the masked out version of that example
and then Y which is like usually just
going to be everything else so typically
X tilde and Y are just going to be
disjoint sub-regions of the input so in
the image example it's literally like
partitioning the image and one part is X
tilde the other part is y
and then we're going to make a
prediction with our our model f Theta
that gets not X but X tilde is input and
then we'll compute our loss so our loss
is going to be between Y which is the
sort of held out part of the input and Y
hat which is what our model thought the
held out part of our input is
in some cases the target might just be
all of X not just the held out part but
this is a relatively minor detail that
doesn't make a huge difference in
practice
and so these highlighted parts are
basically our our design choices or our
control knobs and two of them are pretty
much the same as regular Auto encoders
the model and the the loss function it's
really just this masking function that
we are now able to Define which which
gives us sort of one more knob to turn
and so again as an example in the case
of an image we'll split it up into two
sub-regions and our our model might be a
confinet or a Transformer which we'll
talk about a little later
and our distance function might just be
L2 distance
um in the case of of language or or
one-dimensional sequences we might just
mask out a couple of the the words or
the the tokens in our sequence and
that's sort of our noisy input and our
targets are just uh the the words that
that were there or the original data
there
here often and pretty much all the time
now the model that we use as a
Transformer such as Bert which again
we'll we'll talk about soon
and the the loss function of the
distance function here is usually KL
Divergence
um or cross entropy between the model's
predicted distribution of what it thinks
the missing words were um and what they
actually were
okay so probably to talk about a couple
of uh specific instantiations of this
framework
probably the most famous one is Bert
which which maybe you've heard about
which is this large Transformer model
that's pre-trained on a huge amount of
text that's really good for fine tuning
on new uh usually classification tasks
um and and basically uh Bert gets as
input two sentences but that's sort of a
detail of Bert training it computes
representations of the sentences
um and then it predicts basically the
missing words in both of those sentences
and it just does this task for many many
TPU hours and then you get out a good
model at the end
so let's look at this in a little more
detail
so again we might have
um this this text input and here again
as sort of just a quirk of Bert we use
two sentences instead of just one for
training but it doesn't it's not a huge
uh it's not hugely important
and so we we apply our masking function
which gives us our masked out version of
that input and I've just annotated the
time step in the sequence here that
hopefully will make things a little
easier to see what's going on
and so I've randomly sampled three of
the time steps to mask out
and I'm going to Define my targets which
are just the original words there
and then we stick this entire sequence
with the mass tokens through Bert and
that gives us a prediction for every
time step in the sequence of what the
the word is likely to be the the
probability distribution over all words
of what it thinks the word is there that
probability distribution isn't very
interesting except for the time steps
where we masked out the word because for
all the other time steps we know what
the word is so we just compute our loss
on those massed out time steps and this
this gives us basically three
distributions that are actually needed
for training which is the model's
distribution for time step two for time
step six and time step 9.
and our last function here again is
going to be KL Divergence and this is
this is going to work out to be the
cross entropy between the sort of one
hot distribution that is our our actual
labels here so basically a one on Biden
and a zero for everything else and the
the distribution that our model
predicted for each of those time steps
so that what that works out to be is the
negative log likelihood of Biden on this
distribution for time step two the
negative log likelihood of president for
this distribution at time step six and
the negative log likelihood of was at
this time step nine and we we just sum
those or really average uh often in
practice
and this is our our loss for training
and then we just optimize this end to
end and we are happy
just a couple of details about the way
that Bert does masking just for
completeness
um
masks out 15 of the time steps at random
just uniformly and of these 15 80 of
them get replaced by literally The Mask
token that I've used here and the other
20 actually get replaced with just a
random word instead of a mask token
um
and I'm curious if you just think for a
moment why we might want to use a
mixture of mass tokens and random tokens
instead of just replacing it with a mask
token all the time if you think about
how we're ultimately going to use this
model once we've pre-trained it
[Music]
yeah so you definitely you definitely
don't want to sort of overfit to the
types of sentences that you see during
training but it's sort of a specific
type of sentence we're only seeing
during that we would only be seeing
during training that we want to avoid
and that that's what I'm I'm trying to
get at
also be able to correct but thanks right
so so we in other words we also want to
have good representations of words that
are not mask tokens right so so in a
sense during training if we replace a
word with a random word and we ask our
model to tell us what the original word
was there now our model in addition to
just filling in Mass tokens is also
basically solving this task of for every
word in the sequence assume the word
that you see here is not what was
actually there in the original text what
do you think the word would have been
and so now we have a model that not only
gives us good representations of words
that are masked out but every word in
the sentence and that's important
because at fine tuning time right we're
going to be getting sentences that have
no Mass tokens and then we're just going
to be shoving like real data into the
model and we don't want to be over fit
like you were saying to only the data we
see in training which always has mass
tokens in it so that's sort of the
motivation for why we sometimes actually
just mix in a random word
yeah someone predicting the identity of
one Mass token you cannot see the
identity of the other Mass tokens no
yeah and that and that um that's for
computational reasons I mean you could
you could only mask one token at a time
but then you're sort of using only a
very small amount of your sequence for
training at every time step
um and you have to make your batch very
big and and the the thing that makes
that difficult is now you basically need
to tune this percentage of the input
that you're masking right if you don't
mask enough then you're not really like
learning very quickly because you're
only predicting one word at a time but
if you mask too much now the task is too
hard because you can only see like a
couple words and there's like a lot of
blood has been spilled like trying to
figure out like the right way to sort of
do that masking
um and and that is a perfect segue to
this final point is it is possible that
we can do better than just picking
random time steps
um and and two common ways people do
this are they mask out longer spans of
text at a time so not just like a single
word here and a single word there and
also do what we call Salient span
masking so looking for kind of
information dense parts of the the
sequence or the image and masking those
out instead of just like masking out
random words like was or on or something
and in certain settings these can make a
huge difference in how good your
pre-trained model is we have three
questions I think I saw you and then you
and then you
um is there being any work on looking at
how similar the random tokens are versus
like right how similar the random tokens
are to the brown trees tokens and how
that might affect birth training
outcomes
you wanted to be you can make it should
be more difficult to by making it like
somehow semantically similar right
exactly yeah it's a good question I'm
not aware of uh actually ablating the
the Criterion for how you pick a random
token as far as I know bird just samples
uniformly from the entire vocabulary
but it would be interesting to see if
you if you pick synonyms basically is
that harder yeah it's a good question
uh someone back here
um
what the original word was
yeah
yes
oh yeah yeah sure sure so so the last
question was just that um uh what do you
actually do when you put in a random
word what are you predicting and the the
ideas you replace like for position nine
your place was with like apple and then
the model has to predict what word
originally was there
um what do you say we're selecting for
information that spans and since it's
like what we're saying is we're looking
for something with like high entropy or
whatever yeah it's a good question so
the question was when I say information
dense spans what does that actually mean
um there are a lot of your six people
use but uh oftentimes people will just
take another model that has been trained
to recognize essentially like dates and
names and just like pick out all the
dates and names which often end up being
high entropy portions of the text right
if you say my name is blank it's gonna
be extremely high entropy distribution
right because it could just be anything
so essentially that but but it's
difficult to actually compute the
entropy itself so we use this proxy
which is classifying the type of word it
is
um that's a good question I guess I
would suspect that
um using random tokens are a little bit
more damaging than mask tokens because
for a mask token the model sort of knows
it can ignore that time step there's no
information there whereas if you replace
everything with a random token the model
sort of now has to solve two tasks first
it has to figure out which are the time
steps that have like real tokens and
which are the ones that don't have real
tokens and then once it has figured that
out then it has to try to figure out
what was the original token for those
time steps where they are sort of
determined to be false so I don't know
that's just my one potential guess but
it seems like it could just be harder
but it's a good question
on all the tokens
um so for Bert we just compute the loss
on the masked out tokens because the
oh no I'm sorry including the random so
yeah the the losses just computed on
tokens that are perturbed so masked or
replaced with a random token but the
tokens that are not changed we don't
compute a loss
tries to change the tokens which weren't
supposed to be changed
we just we don't even we don't compute a
loss for those tokens at all so it
doesn't matter but intuitively what
should happen is since we are replacing
some of the tokens with random words
Bert sort of should be acting as if like
every word might have been replaced with
a random word and so it should be giving
you a representation at every time step
that is useful for predicting kind of
the likely words that would have gone
there
[Music]
absolutely they're pretty rare but there
are people who who basically use Bert to
come up with adversarial things to mask
out to like train another model like
Bert
um I'm gonna move on because just
because we have a lot of content but
I love the questions I really do
um okay so so zooming back out from Bert
um I hope that was useful to see that in
a little more detail but um although
bird is the most famous this sort of
masked pre-training kind of approach is
not a language specific phenomenon and
especially recently people found that
this worked really really well for
learning representations of images too
um
and and also with Transformers so it's
it's a very very similar uh kind of
learning setup so here for an image what
we do is we we chop the image up into a
sequence essentially
um so we we uh turn the image into a
grid of like sub regions or patches
we mask out in this case instead of 15
we mask out 75 which gives you some
sense of like the like way that
information is spread out or how
information dense like the signals are
in these two cases which is sort of
interesting but
um first we just mask out tokens the
exact same way we do in language just a
different percent
and then we compute the representations
in this case of only the unmasked
patches so we we
um we flatten out that sequence of all
the patches that didn't get masked out
we stick them through our encoder we get
a representation of all of those and
then we insert placeholder patches into
all the locations that were masked out
so now we have sort of the same shape as
our original image and in the the places
that weren't masked we have our models
representation and then the places that
were masked we just have placeholder
tokens
and then we run this through a decoder
to get a prediction of what the the rest
of the image looked like
and so at fine tuning time we just throw
away the decoder we just use the output
of the encoder but with the whole image
and this is this is really really a
powerful learning setup as well and
actually this sort of mass autoencoder
pre-training can give state of the art a
few shot image classification
performance I mean actually can do
better than supervised pre-training so
if you do this procedure on imagenet and
then fine-tune on imagenet with labels
you can actually do better than if you
just trained on imagenet with labels
from the get-go so in a sense you're
sort of extracting even more information
from your training data set by doing
this procedure and then fine-tuning with
labels and if you just train with all
the labels to to start so that's pretty
cool
but in addition to that
um one thing I think that's interesting
is to compare with contrastive learning
so this is a really I think informative
figure to get a sense of maybe some of
the strengths and weaknesses of mass
auto encoders versus contrastive
learning and the interesting regime I
think is right here so here we have Mae
which is this Mass autoencoder model for
images and then Moco is this momentum
contrast contrastive learning method
sort of V3 but you know whatever
and what's really interesting is that if
we don't do any fine tuning and we just
fit we freeze the pre-trained model and
we just fit a linear head on top of the
Frozen models representations
contrastive Learning Works significantly
better than the mass auto encoder so
it's a difference of a a little more
than four percent but if you actually
fine-tune some of the model itself it
seems that the the Mast Auto encoder
pre-trained models fine tune better than
the contrast of pre-trained models and
so you have it's almost like a little
bit of a trade-off of representation
quality of the the Frozen pre-trained
model versus like find tunability so
it's not clear that it's actually a
trade-off but it seems like for for
these two classes of Methods at least
right now the the contrastive models
give you slightly better representations
but the mask models uh may be fine-tuned
a little better
so if you have like only a tiny bit of
fine-tuning data Maybe the contrastive
models are better because you don't have
enough data to like fine-tune a lot of
the model but if you have a decent
amount of fine tuning data which which
often we we have you know more than like
30 examples in the hundreds of examples
uh the the masked methods can work
really well
so now we've talked a lot about
Transformers
um
and I should say that uh
mass auto encoders work really well and
and they you know I've gotten a lot of
attention but sort of one of the things
I think that has been the engine of a
lot of that progress is the Transformer
architecture because
um to do this sort of mask completion
task requires a high capacity model that
you can scale and in order to apply this
recipe across data modalities it's nice
if you have some architecture that's not
really modality specific and
Transformers give you that so
Transformers are the sort of general
purpose architecture that you can pretty
much just like directly point at
language or images or molecules or like
sequences of states and actions and
reinforcement learning you don't really
need to change the architecture and so
it makes it really easy to kind of
Transport this masked representation
learning approach to new modalities so I
think it's important that we spend a
little time just looking at Transformers
some of you might be familiar with it
already but hopefully you'll learn
something
so okay what is a Transformer so we've
got a little bit of a peak um in in the
the previous slides yeah
um let me think about that
no
um I don't have a concise answer for why
I would expect this to be the case
um
I guess I guess one way and so that
means my short answer is I don't have an
answer I'm very confident in if I had to
totally Hazard a guess I guess you could
say that
um
the the pre-training objective for
contrastive learning is a little bit
more like just doing classification like
like we saw on that early slide right
like we're we're basically coming up
with a a classification score for the
positive pair compared to other other
Pairs and so
um it's almost like you're pre-training
like in a pseudo-supervised way so it
kind of makes sense that if your
Downstream task is to do image
classification maybe pre-training this
way is going to work pretty well without
changing the model at all whereas like
the masked pre-training approaches is a
little more different than
classification but maybe you're
extracting more signal from the data and
so if you're able to fine-tune the model
it'll work better but because the
pre-training objective is a little
different than your Downstream task it's
not necessarily going to work as well
with like no fine tuning at all
that's the best I can give you
oh gosh sorry yeah the question was do
we have any intuition for why
um
contrasting methods might give us better
representations but not fine-tune as
well and the the tldr was that maybe the
contrastive objective is a little closer
to doing classification based on the the
derivation we saw before and so maybe
kind of makes sense that without any
fine tuning they do better at
classification
okay so Transformers
um this is a nice figure from The Vision
Transformer paper that I I thought is a
good at least uh 20 000 foot view of
um the the inputs and outputs of a
transformer so
um we haven't cracked into the the main
meat of it yet but um to see sort of
what's going in coming out of the model
um Transformers operate on sequences of
data and sequence in the very general
sense so this can be a sequence of words
it can be a sequence of here image
patches it could be a sequence of like
Bonds in a molecule it can be kind of
whatever you want
and so the way a Transformer works is
um we we somehow convert our data into a
one-dimensional sequence
we convert these into a sequence of
embeddings so in the case of an image
patch we just have like a linear
transformation that takes like our you
know whatever 16 by 16 grid of pixels
and projects it into some
um usually like something like 768 or
you know 1024 dimensional embedding
space so now we have this sequence of
image patch embeddings
and then before we stick this into our
actual Transformer encoder we do one
extra thing which is really important
um sort of two first we concatenate what
we call a class token in the beginning
of the sequence and this is just because
at the end when we actually want to make
a classification score we need to like
we need to pick one of these
representations to actually like stick
in our final predictor MLP and so we
just have a special token in the
beginning for that but the really
important thing is we have this thing
that we call the position embedding so
we get our our embedding for each image
patch here but we concatenate this this
like number which really in practice
isn't literally a number but it's it's
an embedding that is specific to each
like literal position in the sequence
um and this actually turns out to be
really really important because the
Transformer architecture itself doesn't
discriminate between locations in the
sequence so it's just giving you an
output that's a function of like the set
of things you put into it and so if you
don't add something to tell the model
that this is the embedding at you know
position one and this is the embedding
at position two you'll end up with a
model that's sort of totally permutation
invariant of your input so if you
totally scrambled like the patches in
the image you'd get the same output and
like that is not that's not good we want
our model to be able to reason about the
relative position of things
okay so what's inside this Transformer
encoder the Transformer encoder has a
few main pieces that we'll dig into in
more detail in the next slide but at a
high level we basically have this
fundamental block that we just apply
over and over and over so we'll have
something like 5 or 10 or up to like 100
of these blocks that we apply in a row
and then we just take the output of the
final block and inside each one of those
um what do we do well first we do we
have a normalization step where we just
take every embedding in our sequence and
we normalize it separately so every
embedding should have zero mean and
standard deviation one
then we do what we call multi-head
attention which is basically the only
step in this whole process where the
embeddings at like time step one and
another time step will interact with
each other so this is where all of the
inter time step interaction occurs and
we'll go into the math of what exactly
is happening later
we have a residual connection that wraps
around both of these
and then we have another normalization
step and then we apply an MLP just
separately to every time step so again
there's no communication between the
embeddings at different time steps it's
just a sort of wait tight MLP and then
we have another residual connection that
skips both both of these and then we
have you know 12 or 24 of these blocks
that we train end to end
so sort of the high level picture of
um the the mechanism in the Transformer
and again this multi-cat attention is
the only time where reasoning across
time steps and it does so in a totally
sort of order independent way
and another thing that's worth noting is
that really the only difference between
Transformers for different modalities
again is this initial embedding step so
if you want to you know apply a
Transformer to your new type of data
whether it's you know language or code
or molecules or images or 3D Point
clouds or whatever all you need to do is
figure out how to take my original data
which is like you know the raw data and
turn it into some sequence and then you
stuff in the Transformer and usually
you'll get something reasonable there
are definitely better and worse ways to
do that so I don't want to make it seem
like a trivial Point
um but it but it is pretty much the only
decision you need to make
all right because let's look at things
in a little bit more detail and you know
this is one of the denser parts of the
lecture so you know feel free to ask
questions if if I've not explained
anything adequately
but here let's let's look at a language
example just to like not get too focused
on one modality or another
so we get some input sequence in this
case it's a sequence of words and we
have t uh elements in this input
sequence
we're here T is six
and the first step that we're going to
do is is for for language we're going to
do a tokenization step and this is
needed to basically convert our words
into indices
because that's how we're ultimately
going to convert them into vectors so we
have literally a big mapping
um that we we store that we fit using
like a large Corpus of text and every
every word or really in practice like
sub word sequence of letters just gets
assigned some number
so that's sort of the first step here
and then the second step is to do this
embedding lookup where
um every every index every token index
has its own learned vector and this is
how we're going to get our initial input
sequence to our Transformer so every
word gets a number and then we just look
at the row in our big embedding Matrix
at corresponding to each of these token
indices and that's sort of our initial
embedding
the only asterisk there is we add a
positional embedding like we said before
to to be able to know that you know the
word Joe came first in the sequence not
tenth in the sequence
so this is sort of that first step
outside of the gray box on this last
slide um this is sort of preparing our
initial embeddings to then put into our
many Transformer blocks and this is how
we do this in the in the language
setting
all right so then let's get to the the
gray box that's what we're all here for
um so again this is just one Transformer
block and in practice we're gonna you
know have many of these in sequence all
with different parameters that we that
we learn
and the first thing that we do is we're
going to normalize all of these vectors
in our sequence independently so each of
these vectors is going to have mean 0
and unit standard deviation and so again
we have this this chunk now of T by D
where our sequence length is T and D is
the the actual embedding Dimension or
the hidden hidden State dimension of our
model
then we have this this self-attention
step which is sort of where the magic
happens so to speak where we will
compute this self-attention Matrix which
essentially tells us how related or how
similar the token at one location is to
a token at another location and this is
kind of what tells us like how we should
be propagating information between time
steps and this is sort of hypothesized
to be what makes Transformers really
powerful is that it can do this explicit
sort of point-to-point reasoning instead
of for an RNN where if you have
information here that's relevant to
something much later in the sequence you
have to kind of recognize that here and
then remember it as you process all of
the tokens in between the differences
with the Transformer I'm directly
comparing each token to every other
token so I don't have to do that
okay so how does that work
well we compute a new set of
representations a which is the same
shape as the input representations but
it has this particular form which is
maybe a little bit like what the hell at
first but we'll go through it one step
at a time so
um the there are there are really two
main pieces so this is this a again is
the output of the self-attention step
and the two main pieces are what we call
the self-attention Matrix and the value
Matrix so the self-attention Matrix is
this thing that I've drawn right here
this is the the T by T Matrix that tells
us how similar is the thing at one
location to a thing at another location
and the value Matrix is basically like
if I say that my representation at this
time step really only depends on the
thing at this other time step the value
Matrix tells you what is the what is the
actual representation that you're going
to be pulling from that other time step
that's going to replace your your
current representation
to be to be more specific about this so
xq is just your input here x times sum d
by D or or even a down projection to a
lower Dimension but some transformation
matrix which is a linear transform and
then the same thing with XK it's just
another learned linear transform and
again with XV it's just another linear
transform so you just have three
different projections of your input
vectors
and you take
um to get your attention Matrix you take
the inner product of all pairs of what
we can call the the queries and the keys
and this gives us some Matrix and then
we do a soft Max to sort of normalize
each row to sum to one so every every
time step basically gets assigned a
distribution over all time steps in the
sequence and then when we do this matrix
multiplication with the value Matrix
what we're doing is we're doing a
weighted sum over the value Vector for
every time step in the sequence weighted
by the softmax attention score for each
of those time steps
and
yeah so so when we do this when we do
this final matrix multiplication to get
a
so he the question was can you say that
sentence again
um the answer is no but I'll try to be
similar because I don't remember what I
said essentially what a is doing is for
every time step so the value of A1 is is
roughly just going to be a weighted sum
over
um over each XV so that the the
projected version of each one of these
vectors weighted by the attention score
for each one of these time steps so so
this self-attention Matrix is this T by
T thing meaning for each time step in
our length T sequence we have a length T
vector and that Vector is a probability
distribution over all of the time steps
and we just do a weighted sum over the
over their value vectors
and so just as an example like if this
is our self-attention Matrix literally
like the number right here in The Matrix
is going to be like X of the inner
product of the third row of the query
Matrix and the second row of the key
Matrix over the sum of the X of the
third row of the query Matrix and all of
our keys
that's this is just the softmax but I've
just written it out for like a
particular cell
yes
[Music]
um and the MLPs
yeah so after self-attention
um we do another residual connection and
normalization and then we have a an MLP
that we apply it's the same MLP for
every time step it's the weights are
shared but it's just sort of like a
post-processing on the output of
self-attention but yeah so now it's all
the parameters so it's the xq or the WQ
the WK the WV and then this is a one
hidden layer MLP so we have two wave
matrices here and that's all the
parameters other than like your input
embedding Matrix which is relatively few
parameters yes
yeah it's not obvious but yes
um mathematically it's equivalent so
actually in an early version of this
slide I wrote it out with just the
collapsed single Matrix because like
when you do the transpose of XK right we
get x times WQ times w k transpose times
x transpose so you can just Define a new
Matrix that's wqwk transpose and it's
like it's the same right but it's not
the same because when you train it turns
out it's like easier to train if you
have both of the matrices because when
you do one step of gradient descent like
you're going to update
while we're getting the weeds but like
each Matrix is going to get like a rank
one update and if you have a product of
two matrices they both get a rank one
update so like the update you make to
each of them to the thing and aggregate
is is richer so in some sense it's like
easier to optimize it's not totally well
understood but um yeah people still do
it with this like double Matrix way
because it just seems to work better
it's a good question though
it's a good question
I don't know the answer to that
I think he was first belonging tonight
what do you mean by rank one update
and now we're officially in the weeds
but I'm happy to talk oh
yeah
good so someone's paying attention at
least
um so this is not multi-head attention
this is single-headed attention and so
really what we'll do with multi-headed
tension is we won't do this once we'll
actually repeat this basically this wqwk
and WV matrices will all have an extra
index which will be the heads and so
you'll repeat this like eight times in
parallel
and each one of them will take like a
will project usually like a different
Subspace of X because
right so like if you have like yeah
basically one of the words in the
sentence might be related to like it
might have multiple senses for example
and so you know if you have the word
Bank like maybe it's related to like
River because it's like a riverbank but
maybe it's also related to like you know
Federal Reserve and like you haven't
disambiguated what kind of Bank it is
yet so you want to attend to both but
you want to do them separately so you do
them in the two different heads and then
later on you combine them
but yeah that's sort of a detail of like
real Transformers that uh we'll admit
for now
okay and so oh yeah yeah
usually after sorry
that's a great question uh it's pretty
much purely empirically
um decided as far as I know there are
some papers that um uh try to analyze
some of these decisions and and give
rationales behind them uh there's a
there's a paper I think called like
Transformer circuits or a mathematical
framework for for Transformer
architectures or something like this
from anthropic that
gets into this in more detail but
um my understanding is this largely
because it's what works best but I'm not
sure actually the the location of the
normalization makes a huge difference in
the final performance it's kind of
arbitrary
okay
yes
um
positional embeddings work are they uh
like how do you make them so that the
Transformers
um so it's it's literally um your
embedding lookup gives you like a t by D
sequence so you have a sequence of
length T and you do your embedding
lookup and you get a d length Vector for
each time step your positional
embeddings can literally just be like a
stack of learned vectors and like you
have one for the thing at time Step Zero
and one for the thing at time step one
and so on and so forth and you actually
just literally add them together
and that's what forms your input
sequence and you just learn them and
then
there are other ways of doing it that
like aren't learned that also work and
there are more complicated ones that
like try to make it easier to generalize
to longer sequences than you saw during
training but like the basic idea is it's
just like a vector you add to the
to the raw inputs
all right
I'm going to move on
so the last question was your question
which was
um
remember your questions again
right right yeah so so the question was
about the positional embeddings and
where do they actually come from and
basically it's just you have a learn
Vector for every time step in your
sequence and for each quarter planning
time step you just look up the one at
that index there are more complicated
ways of doing it but
um
okay so now we have the gray box which
is great because we love it
um and we're pretty much done now so we
have lots of these blocks and we train
them all end to end and we get some
representation for every time step in
our sequence and then finally if for
example we're doing like Mast
pre-training we just have a final linear
transform that projects the
representation at every time step into
the dimensionality of our vocabulary and
then we do a soft Max this gives us a
distribution over all the words in our
vocabulary and now we can just do like
you know maximum likelihood training or
whatever
um and and this is this is pretty much
the whole thing
cool
all right so we've talked about
pre-training we've talked about
Transformers how do we actually
fine-tune these guys once we have them
pre-trained so um let's look at one more
example so here I've appended I've
pre-pended this class token that we
talked about before because it's not
really needed to understand pre-training
but for fine tuning we're going to use
it so
um we're going to to just push this
sequence through our model and when we
do fine-tuning oftentimes we'll just
take the representation of the class
token and we'll fine-tune a new
prediction head which is often just a
linear transform or a small MLP on top
of this class token representation
because that's pretty straightforward
that's pretty much what we said before
we were talking about regular Auto
encoders but you know one of the big
questions on on hopefully on your mind
is what do we do with
um what do we do with this guy uh during
fine tuning so I mean you know we could
freeze the these parameters we could
fine-tune all of them
um
there are other options maybe we
fine-tuned some of them or we could
freeze them but inject some new
parameters that we're going to fine-tune
and turns out in practice people usually
do sort of option three here so in some
sense they kind of freeze and fine-tune
them in in lots and lots of different
ways and we're gonna we're gonna look at
one of these these methods in a little
more detail so that you have some
intuition about what that actually means
and the method that we're going to look
at which again there are many and I
don't mean to pick this one as like the
end-all be-all but I think it's
reasonably concise to to get your your
arms around so I think it can be uh
useful to work through it's called low
rank adaptation of language models
and again the intuition is like we want
to fine-tune our model a little bit in
some sense so we don't want to
necessarily fine tune all the parameters
of our model because we don't want to
destroy all of the knowledge in the
model
um and and you know
of course there's a question of like
what does a little bit even mean so
um I'm curious if people have just like
a sense of if we want to fine tune our
really big model we want to fine tune it
kind of a little bit just enough to
learn the task but not too much like
what what is what would that
what would that mean to you in terms of
maybe what a method might look like or
what we might want to avoid what failure
modes we might observe
yeah
perhaps maybe um you don't want it to
lose the ability to do the original task
or like
you don't want the
the whole probability distribution
between the smart term right
how to use this problem
right so in some sense we want to
preserve the original model
um because if we totally throw away the
original model
what's the point of starting from the
pre-trained model yeah
Okay so let me go backwards
yeah so the class token actually is in
the vocabulary it's just another
usually it's like token zero in the
vocabulary and it does show up during
pre-training
um for Bert there's there's actually I
omitted one thing about Bird Training
um which is that
um we don't just do the mass language
modeling
there's actually this extra task this
next sentence prediction task where we
take the representation of the class
token and we just do binary
classification which is whether these
two sentences are consecutive sentences
or not it's like half the time you'll
sample two random sentences from your
data set half the time they'll be one
after another and you just have to do
this classification and that's how we
sort of train that representation
but later work it showed that you
actually don't need to do that it
doesn't really make a difference
distributable
books
yeah so as far as I know the class token
is just it's in the input during
training but it's not yeah it's not used
I don't think you mask it because it'll
always be the class token so it'd be
sort of generate but you still get
decent representations out of it yeah
it's kind of kind of mysterious
but there's a there's a file paper
called Roberta which is basically
ablating some of the things in Bert and
turns out you don't need to do the next
sentence prediction thing and you can
still fine-tune It Fun
so if you're curious you can look into
that
okay this is going to take forever
okay uh we are
here okay so we talked about what a
little bit might mean and basically
we've gotten to it which in my mind is
we want to preserve the knowledge in the
pre-trained model we don't want to
totally obliterate everything that's
there
and that's sort of like a a learning
based objective practically speaking we
also want to avoid having to actually
store a new copy of every single
parameter of our model for every new
task that we want to fine-tune on right
like a lot of these pre-trained models
are very big they have hundreds of
millions billions or even hundreds of
billions of parameters it'd be really
annoying if we need like a whole new
copy of the model for every new task
that we want to fine-tune on so the
other motivation here is like we just
don't have to add that much every single
time from like a storage perspective
and so to get into this one method that
that addresses these issues I want to
take a brief walk back in time
um to 1972 uh to to describe this this
sort of particular view on what a linear
transformation actually does which
ultimately gets at this question of what
is a little bit
so consider the fine linear transform
which is the building block of
um neural networks in general but also
Transformers specifically
and we know that for some rank R Matrix
which is a linear transform
we have a decomposition of this form
um
and using this decomposition we know
that if we evaluate the Matrix Vector
product with some input we can just
rewrite it so we can push the X inside
the sum and we have this essentially a
weighted sum of each vector v weighted
by this inner product of X with this
particular U sub r
so this is just like
algebra barely algebra at this point
and one way we can interpret this is
that this Matrix Vector product w x is
really outputting a sum over what we can
think of as memories so each VR is sort
of like a memory and each u r is kind of
like a key that determines how relevant
a particular input is to that memory
right so if if x is totally irrelevant
to a particular memory VR then X that
means X will be orthogonal to u r and so
this inner product will be zero so we
won't include that memory at all in our
output
if x is very aligned with the particular
Ur that means that memory is going to
show up very strongly in our output so
this is not really even new math this is
just kind of another way of thinking
about the linear transformation which is
useful for motivating all sorts of
things in like computational
neuroscience and ultimately machine
learning but it's useful here because
now we can go back to what does it mean
to fine tune a little bit and we can say
well a little bit means we just only
want to add a couple of memories and
what that means is we ultimately just
want to make a low rank change to w
and that's convenient because a low rank
Matrix can be stored much more
effectively than the full rank Matrix so
we've kind of addressed both things here
we're going to preserve most of the
knowledge because the new Matrix is only
going to differ from the original matrix
by some low rank change and we can store
this change very efficiently because a
low rank Matrix is not a lot of
parameters
and that's exactly what Laura does so
when we do fine tuning ultimately we're
going to start with some pre-trained
parameters W naught
these are frozen
and our fine-tuned parameters are just
going to differ from our pre-trained
parameters by some low rank Matrix a b
transpose so both A and B are these d by
P matrices so sorry I should have
written W naught and WFT are d by D so
we're just assuming the Matrix is square
but there's nothing specific to square
matrices here this works perfectly well
for non-square matrices
um and so uh when we compute this matrix
product we get some low rank d by D
Matrix that we add to W naught
um and and we fine tune Just A and B
here so we don't fine tune W naught and
so we only end up needing to store kind
of 2 by D 2 times D times P new
parameters instead of two times D
Squared new parameters for every layer
one minor note is that we we do it's
usually much easier to fine-tune these
models if at the initialization we're
starting out with the same function as
the pre-trained model so that means we
want a b to be initialized with zeros
um but the way we do that is a little
bit tricky so if we initialize both A
and B as all zeros we're actually not
going to get any gradient for either of
them so we won't learn anything and so
if we want the product a b transposed to
B zeros but we want to be able to learn
things we actually need to initialize
one of them as all zeros and the other
with basically non-zero like random
normal random initialization so that's
kind of a detail you'll see that in
homework three but it's something to
keep in mind
so like I said that's Laura I hope that
was somewhat interesting to to think
through but there are there are a lot
lots and lots of of different methods
for lightweight fine-tuning that people
have come up with in the last few years
this is this is one sort of survey of a
lot of them which plots the the
percentage of the parameters of the
original model that actually need to get
updated with the actual accuracy and we
can see at least for this evaluation
which is you know just one Benchmark
Laura is in the you know relatively like
heavy weight in terms of these
lightweight methods but also the high
performing methods
um but keep in mind even though this is
relatively heavy weight it's still only
fine-tuning less than one percent of the
parameters of the model
and what's really interesting is that in
the same paper
um the paper has a nice
direct and audacious title like
lightweight fine-tuning is better than
in context learning or something
um but but sort of their main result
here is that actually this is the case
at least in some settings where uh if
you use some of these lightweight
fine-tuning methods in the right way you
can get better if you shot performance
than a gpt3 model that's like
10 or 100 times bigger
and so in a sense
um if if you have sort of more than a
couple of examples in context learning
is still very powerful if you only have
like one example to adapt on but if you
have a few more if you have in the like
20 to 70 regime which is I think what
they studied in this paper
fine-tuning can can be more parameter
efficient or scale better than in
context learning
but again this is very very hot off the
press so to speak so I don't want to
make any claims that are too categorical
and you actually you'll make a similar
um slightly simpler but a similar
comparison in homework three actually
okay
how are we doing we're doing great good
for us
um
last section
so we talked about reconstruction
as a as a heuristic for representation
learning we've talked about Auto
encoders which are sort of the the first
stab at using this and now we've talked
about Mast Auto encoders which sort of
try to address some of the issues with
them and I want to talk about another
related class of models another sort of
related kind of heuristic for
pre-training which is auto regressive
models which I believe you saw in a
previous lecture on Black Box meta
learning but I want to revisit it in
this context because I think it's it's
interesting
uh so in a sense Auto regressive models
are are very closely related to Mast
Auto encoders
um but but they sort of simplify a
couple things
so first we can think about what some of
the downsides of mass autoencoders
actually are so I mean maybe the most
obvious one is like we have this extra
thing we have to pick like we have to
decide how we're going to do the masking
and like maybe there are better and
worse ways to do that and it's not
always obvious what they are and so it
just like you know causes us stress and
we lose sleep and all sorts of things
there are other things like as as uh
someone asked before
um we're only masking out some of the
examples sometimes it's 15 sometimes at
75 percent you know can we mask out more
why not well we're only using basically
part of each example to train on we're
only using the parts that we masked out
and we're not Computing a loss for all
the other time steps so in a sense we're
not like fully utilizing each training
example
and then finally the downside is that
once we pre-train this thing we can
actually sample from it we can't we
don't have a generative model we can't
sample from the original you know
generate new samples from the new data
distribution which sometimes is
interesting and fun
okay so basically the idea behind Auto
aggressive models is we're going to
Simply ask well instead of masking out a
random subset of the input What If
instead our sort of learning objective
is just take a prefix of the input and
predict the next word or the next pixel
or the next token or the next patch or
whatever
so now we don't have to pick a masking
strategy at all in a sense we're masking
every token
and so what we're going to learn is
simply this this Auto regressive model
which which parameterizes a distribution
over the next token or the next word or
whatever given the proceeding
so if we have again a training sequence
like Joe Biden is the U.S president
we're going to actually convert this
into six different training examples by
masking out uh every word in the
sequence and conditioning on the ones
before it
so we don't really have this constraint
of only using 15 of the example anymore
because we're Computing a loss on every
single time step
and here I've added a beginning of
sequence token because we need sort of
something to put in the model to get our
first prediction for what the first word
is going to be so so one difference here
is for Mass language models sort of the
output at a particular time step is what
we think that word is if it's masked
here the output at a particular time
step is what we think the next word is
going to be so we have this like shift
by one going on
so what this looks like when we actually
stick it into our model is we have X
naught which is just a BOS token so we
put that in our Auto aggressive model
and this gives us some distribution over
next tokens given just BOS
and then we look at the next token in
the sequence and this is used as both
the input at the next stage as well as
the target for the previous stage so X1
is um is actually the target y 0. and
then we also put this combined sequence
through our model so now we have BOS and
Joe and we get a prediction over what we
think the next
token is going to be and then we roll
this out so we see the next token we see
Biden that's the target for the previous
step and it's also the the sort of
incremental input for this step and we
do this forever and ever
so I so this is great we can do this and
you can write papers that people will
talk about a lot which is awesome
but I think I've sort of cheated a
little bit here in terms of comparing
Auto aggressive models to mass
autoencoders so I've said how
um
you know with mass auto encoders we only
mask out 15 of the example we're not
using the whole example here we're
masking out everything that's great
but I left something out and you might
be wondering
well why can't we just do mass auto
encoding but like use the same example
multiple times
until we've mashed out everything right
if we're masking out 20 well we'll just
mask it out five different times we'll
use a different 20 every time and now
we've used the whole example
and that's totally true we can do
exactly that
but the difference is for an auto
aggressive Transformer the
representation that we compute for each
prefix is independent of all the stuff
that comes later
and the significance of that is we can
actually do this sort of efficient
training where we mask out everything
really efficiently and what I mean by
that is we only have to compute a new
representation for sort of the the
marginal new token at every time step so
when we're when we're predicting what
the first token is going to be we have
to compute a representation of POS but
then when we're predicting the second
token we can actually just reuse the
representation we computed of BOS and we
just have to compute the representation
of the one new word that we're seeing
and so on and so forth and so if we were
doing this with a masked autoencoder
every time we change a single mask since
the attention is going both ways the
representation for every token depends
on every other token in the sequence if
we change just one mask we have to do a
completely new forward pass of our model
on the entire sequence whereas here
every time we add a new token we only
have to actually compute one new
representation and so this makes
um that the fact that our sort of
attention is only looking backwards
makes it much more efficient to do this
so that's why we really are gaining
something over just doing mass auto
encoding with different masks
to use these models for like spell
checking or something like that where
you really wouldn't want to look into
those directions yeah so so uh one of
the trade-offs that I think I'll mention
in the summary is that
um the the the representation quality is
a little bit worse for other aggressive
models in general because you're you
have a more constrained model it can
only look One Direction
um so so you have some benefits but you
also have some drawbacks yeah
yeah so so no so the way we get around
that actually is maybe easiest to
visualize if we just look at this
attention map
um I drew here so basically what's going
to happen
um for the auto aggressive Transformer
everything is the same except what you
end up doing is you literally zero out
all of the attention scores that are on
the upper half of the attention map and
so literally when you when you do this
weighted sum
um all of the terms in this soft Mass
Max Matrix which would would be the
attention of a token to a token in the
future are manually set to zero so they
can affect the output
future look at myself
representations
[Music]
right no so so the representation of a
token at time T only depends on the
tokens before
t
so so if I if I have
um in the auto aggressive case
foreign
the representation for Biden this is
only a function of the representations
of Joe and BOS so when I add is for my
next training example
um the representation of Biden is going
to be the same because again it's only
going to be a function of the words that
come before it so if I add words after
it they don't factor into the
representation of Biden at all
so what should I could change
um
so it's a question that when I add a new
word
is that going to change the
representation of previous tokens
because
yeah so in a sense this is a limitation
so the question is yeah when we add new
words don't we want the representation
of Prior words to change because like
it's extra context and in a sense yes we
in a perfect model we would be able to
do that but by making the simplification
we have some other benefits which is
that we can do this form of masking and
reuse the representations if we didn't
have this constraint that you know the
attention map the map was masked in this
way we would have to do a complete new
forward pass for every example it'd be
much much less efficient
and we also want to be able to sample
from the model because it wouldn't give
us an actual Auto regressive
distribution that we can sample one
token at a time and just condition on
the past stuff
yeah one more and then we'll move
forward with a couple more slides
where is the v-model produces next is
completely wrong is that wrong
representation so cash should use to
predict a few tools yeah that's a good
question so during training we do what
we call teacher forcing so we
oh sorry yeah so if if the model samples
like a bad word basically like a random
word like Joe Biden dog
um you know what's going to happen
during training we don't use samples
from the model we we sort of only use as
input a prefix of our training data and
just predict the next word so we never
actually use like a prediction of our
model as part of the training process
but at sampling time this can happen
where basically like your model will by
some bad fortune sample kind of a random
or low probability word and it'll get
totally derailed and it'll just start
saying like dog dog and then like you
just have to stop generating and try
again
of the cost representation since we
already have the embeddings of all the
time so you're just directly not doing
right well well so the representation
here of Biden is not just going to be of
the word Biden it's going to be Biden in
the context of Joe yeah so it's instant
specific
so yeah that's important we're not just
caching the representation of individual
words we're caching the representation
of this prefix of the sequence in this
specific context
so sort of caching within a single batch
and so just to hammer this Home Auto
aggressive Transformers are all over the
place these days so you have the whole
GPT family but you also have Megatron
which is a model from Nvidia you have
opt which is sort of an open
reproduction of GPT from some
researchers that meta
just because they were later doesn't
mean we can laugh at them okay
we love being meta and then there's a
other open efforts from not from
companies from from open source uh
communities like GPT Neo
and their models for vision too that are
Auto aggressive Transformers for RL and
for decision making for navigating the
web I mean also for multimodal settings
for vision and language so so one case
study of this is a model from deepmind
called Flamingo and they're sort of
getting at this question of like how
would you build a multimodal auto
regressive model and hopefully the
answer is not from scratch and that's
what they sort of show in this paper so
for the most part what we've been
showing is fine-tuning as a form of
specialization so we take a general
purpose model we use few shot data to
make it a task specific model but in
Flamingo what they do is they use fine
tuning as a way to actually just combine
two pre-trained models so they have a
pre-trained autoregressive language
model and a pre-trained vision feature
extractor and they fine tune with a
little bit of multimodal data to get
this autoregressive image language model
and I'm not going to go through the
architecture because we're running a
little low on time but it's it's it's it
looks kind of weird but it's actually
pretty straightforward
but what's really interesting about it
is you do this Auto aggressive
pre-training basically with unsupervised
data scraped from the web of websites
that have both images and text and now
you get a model that you can do fuse
shot prompting the way you can with jpt3
but you can have images in the input too
so you can do sort of few shot image
captioning or visual question answering
and what's kind of cool is that actually
the few shot performance of the largest
version of their model actually
approaches state of the art for models
that are fine-tuned like on the whole
training set so it's pretty cool
one little note is is just that um our
Auto regressive model is actually
different from Mass autoencoders and to
skip right to the punch line the answer
is no in a sense and auto across an auto
aggressive model is really just a mass
auto encoder with a specific form of the
Mask function where we just X is just a
prefix of X tilde is just a prefix of X
and Y is just the next token
okay so just just to summarize today we
talked about sort of the main intuition
for auto encoders which is that a good
representation is one that lets us
reconstruct the input and we talked
about Mast Auto encoders which are a
modification of this Basic Auto encoder
that restores sort of a partially
deleted input and this helps avoid some
of the degeneracies of unmasked
autoencoders
these mass auto encoders are state of
the art and pre-training in few shot
learning for for both vision and
language
um and and we saw Auto regressive models
which are really a special case of mass
auto encoders
a couple pros and cons of contrastive
models and and auto auto encoders and
mass autoencoders um I don't know if I
need to really enumerate these because I
guess we're right about out of time but
I think the the main uh trade-off that
you can think about is that
um especially using some of these new
contrastive learning methods that don't
require sampling negatives anymore
really one of the biggest trade-offs is
that the contrastive models learn really
high quality representations but the
mass auto encoders might be a little
better if you're actually going to
fine-tune the model so if you if you
just want to compute representations and
like pre-cache all the representations
and then throw away the model maybe the
contrastive model will work a little
better but if you want to keep your
actual pre-trained model around and fine
tune it a bit the mass auto encoders
might work better